日本で家を買うとは
思っていませんでした
日本の家は
美しいけれど
夏には暑すぎて
冬には寒すぎる
安全に そして快適に生活するには
かなりのリノベーションが必要です
それに対して
現代の日本の
モジュラー住宅は正反対
すごく機能的なんです
でも——
日本の昔ながらの家の
温かみと情熱が足りない
別の方法はないと
思っていたのですが
14カ月ほど前に妻が
地域の小さな建築会社を見つけたのです
" シーナリーハウス "
出来上がったのは
単なる家じゃなくて
オフィスでもあり
そして 友達が泊れる場所です
YouTube や Twitch の
仲間が九州に来た時——
うちに来てリラックスして
それぞれ動画を作れる
それで
もう本当に信じられません
当然 僕にとってはハイリスクで
大きな賭けになるのですが
シーナリーハウスが作る空間を
見た時——
予算を超過してでも
思い切って挑戦しなきゃと思ったんです
彼らが本当に特別なものを
作れるようにしたかった
何ひとつ後悔してません
家を見れば
きっと分かります
Tokyo Lens のノームに
とても感謝してます
また マヌという YouTube の友達にも感謝してます
最近 彼の新しいチャンネルでコラボしました
２人ともこの動画作りに
協力してくれました
そして視聴者の皆さんに
心から感謝しています
皆さんがいなければ
成し遂げられませんでした
皆さんのご支援のおかげで
本当に特別ですばらしい家を
建てることができました
心より感謝いたします
皆 家が気になってるかと思いますので
ハウスツアーを始めます
道元とノームとマヌです
僕の家の中です
彼らは初めて僕の家を見ます
これからハウスツアーを始めます
よし　目を開いて
すごい！　きれい
今は玄関にいるんだけど
結構 便利な点があって
ここは客用玄関なんだ
汚い靴とか見ないで通れるんだ
２つあるの？
これが家族用の
シューズインクローゼット
広い！
秘密の部屋みたいだね
自分が家を買うなら
秘密の通路が欲しいんだ
入ってみよう
ノームが今 立ってる所に
ハンガーラックがあって
この玄関の土間の上にあるんだ
石の床
そう　石の床
雨の日の上着を
ここに掛けられる
これを見て
気になったと思うんだ
全体的に
大きな土地なんだけど
いい景色がないから
安かったんだ
でも何かを眺めて欲しいという
建築家の思いがあって
中庭をつくることに
なったんだ
中庭の右側には寝室があって
それ以外が左側にある
リビングとかね
先に家の右側に行こうか
見てみよう
こんな感じ
すごい！
ウソだろ！
作業用の場所？
そう
こっちの部屋は娘たちの部屋
言われたら
すぐ分かると思うんだけど
部屋を真ん中で分けると
対称的になる
完全に対称的
この先 娘たちが
自分の部屋が欲しくなったら
ここに壁を作って
それぞれの部屋ができる
両側からドアが閉まるから
２人とも
自分のドアがあるんだね
そう
もしこの部屋を２つに分けると
部屋が
何と言うか 狭い…
小さい？
小さくなる
勉強机を部屋に置くのではなく
廊下に置くことにしたんだ
すごすぎる
この机は廊下に沿って
続いていて
この棚に教科書とか入る
向こう側にキッチンがあって
本当だ
妻が “ ご飯できたよ ” って
伝えられる
なるほどね
家の反対側から
子供たちを確認できる
裏に照明があるのが
結構いいと思う
よく気づいてくれたね
間接照明だよ
物に反射した光なんだ
間接的に光る感じ
そうそう
僕の寝室に進もうか
ありがとう
すごくいいね
つながってるのかと
思ってたよ
違うんだよ
一周しないんだね
理由は後で分かるよ
あるオプションを付けたんだ
高かったんだけどね
こういう動画を作って
いつか完済できるといいんだけど
そのオプションが
セントラル空調
夏は冷たい空気が
上から下に行って
冬には暖かい空気が
下から上に行く
日本に来て15年経つけど
セントラル空調のある家は
これでたったの３件目だよ
あまり見ないよね
建築家によると
あの大きいエアコンが
無いだけで
全然違う
部屋がすっきりする
本当にそうだと思う
日本では家とか部屋が
すごくきれいでも
エアコンがやっぱり
目立っちゃうんだよね
太い配管が出てて
壁には穴があるし
ノーム　今 触ってる所には
ロールスクリーンを
付ける予定なんだ
なるほど
この家には
カーテンが付いていないんだ
じゃあ 日本のすばらしいトイレを
見ようか
どうぞ お先に
一番大事な部屋！
標準的なやつだよ
まあ標準的なトイレでも
アメリカのと比べると結構いいけどね
入っていいよ
うん
こういう植物も好きだけど
これは会社のかな
建築会社の物だから
回収されるかも
忍者みたいなのが好き
そうだね
気づかれにくい隠れた収納
これからキッチンとか
リビングに行くよ
今まで見た中で
一番いいキッチンだよ
これだ
だよね？
テレビに出るやつ
道元のだよね？
うん　そうそう
最高の質問じゃん
疑問に思ってるんじゃないかな
キッチンフードはどこ？って
どう換気するんだろう？って
あれなの？
そう　あれ
妻がこだわっていて
彼女は結構 料理をするんだ
普通は低いキッチンフードが
付いてるんだけど
別の方法で換気扇を
作れないかって聞いたんだ
なるほど
木とか植物の景色の
邪魔にならないように
それで この排気口の裏に
実はあの中に
強力な送風機があって
空気を排出する
下から来る空気は
外に押し出される
冷蔵庫はここへ
そりゃそうか
当然
ぴったり入るように
作ってくれた
うん
“ 冷蔵庫のサイズに合わせて作るね ” って
また隠れた収納が！
これは妻のキッチンパントリー
この家の一番好きなところを
紹介するよ
それが
この窓
サッシ自体 木製だけど
枠も木製だから
美しいよ
すごい
枠にアルミが一切
使われていないんだ
木だね
そう　木なんだ
もう１回キッチンに戻って
窓を開けた状態で外を見てみよう
召合せの部分が
無くなって大きな…
すごい　絵みたいだ
こんなに窓を大きく開けても
家が囲っているから
強風の心配もない
激しい風とか
なんか言い表せないけど
分かるよな？
あと紅葉の緑と黒の
色合いが好きだ
うん
気に入った
秋には色が変わるの？
うん
それも 美しいだろうな
日本は夏がすごく暑い
夏は苦手
その通り
日差しを遮りたい時も
あるよね
窓にも上の部分にも
カーテンレールは無い
家の日よけには
カーテンじゃなくて
これを取り付けた
かっこいい
いいね
こっち側から撮るといいかも
最高
朝日が昇る時
向こう側から昇るから
ちょうど木の影が見えるんだ
庭が映るんだね
そう
建築家が強調してたんだけど
“ カーテンは使わないんだ ” と
だからその代わりに
障子を使う
かっこよすぎる
リビングに行こう
ここにも障子があるんだね
この障子は
さっきのとは違うんだ
というのも
これは雪見障子なんだ
それで
下だけが…
座ってもいい？
どうぞ
雪が降ったときに使えるんだ
外の様子が垣間見える
向こう側の雪とか
プライバシーも守れるね
そうそう
プライベートを…
上のほうにある窓からも
光が入ってきていいね
明るくなる
ここにも
もう１つの…
畳？　じゃなくて障子だ
これは造作ソファだよ
作りつけなんだ
いい感じ
僕と妻はコーヒー好きでさ
もったいないと思ったんだ
テーブルは使わないんだったら
必要ない
うん
だからコップ置き場があるんだ
いいね
飲んで 置いて みたいな
あれも空調？
そうだよ　よく気づいたね
暖かい空気がソファの下から出る
これは気に入ると思うんだけど
ここにＬＡＮポートがあるんだ
うん
ユーチューバーだからね
いろんな部屋からライブ配信したいから
有線があると便利
最高
この部屋は特に
見た目がよくて
このソファで
インタビューするのが楽しみ
そのまま Twitch で
ライブ配信したりね
この色合い
道元の前のレイアウトに似てるよね
確かに
あのセーターの青色とかね
そうだね
こっちに進もう
できるだけ右手側は
見ないようにしてね
分かった
ここは見てもいいよ
ここは洗濯機を置く場所
洗濯機はそこで
今まで気づかれなかったけど
言ったら思い出すと思う
娘たちと僕の部屋には
クローゼットが無いんだ
その理由としては
ファミリークローゼットがあるから
すごく広い
４人用で
ほかにクローゼットは無いんだ
なるほど
あえて この設計にしてるんだ
洗濯が終わったら一歩出て
クローゼットにしまえばいい
家の反対側まで
運ばなくて済む
考えたことなかったけど
正直 シャワーを浴びる前後は
多くの場合
洗濯機の近くで着替えるよね
どうせ
そう
自分の部屋で着替えることは
めったにないよ
そう
考えたことなかった
自分の下着とかシャツなんて
脱いでから浴室に行くのではなく
洗面台に置くよね
ドアを閉めて着替えればいい
脱衣所みたいな
そうそう
これって鉄棒？
僕も聞きたかった
合ってる　鉄棒だよ
僕は昔
トリッキングをしてて
懸垂とか運動するのが
好きなんだけど
買わないと…
器具を？
大きな器具を
買わないと懸垂できない
日本のドア枠は挟むタイプの
器具には耐えられない
僕の部屋に服を干すための
棒があるんだけど
あるね
懸垂に使っちゃってる
気を付けてね
別府は
日本の温泉都市で
だから別府の多くの家は——
高い安いに関わらず
温泉が付いている
そして ここにも温泉があるんです
千と千尋じゃん
行くよ
きれい
すごい
ウソだろ
窓も設置してある
向こうには庭もあるし
ノーム
さっき一緒に寝室にいたとき
その言い方だと…
あの時 君が言ってた
“ 寝室がつながってないね
一周しないんだ ” って
その理由が温泉水には
サビ付かせる成分が含まれているから
うん
この壁の裏から向こうまで
防水処理してるんだ
温泉があっても
寝室に入らないようにね
湿気がね
そうなんだよ
２本目の紅葉だね
そうだよ
気に入ったね
この中に
座ってみてもいいよ
上が開いててさ
見える？
空が見えるよ
僕はいい感じの温泉が
すごく好きなんだ
いい景色がある温泉
のどかで すてきな所
あとでおすすめ
教えるよ
ぜひ
国関係なく
シャワーで困ってるのが
シャワーヘッドが小さいこと
動き回らないといけない
ここでは問題ない
こんな感じ
僕は背が高いからね
これはね
標準的な高さ
日本ではね
でも
ちょうどいいマイクじゃん
水やりの方法を質問したら
シャワーでいいじゃんって言われた
確かにな
道元
僕の部屋を見てもいい？
もちろん
僕もここに引っ越すんだ
僕は東京に住んでない
ユーチューバーで
２人は東京住みで
お互い簡単に会いに行けない
ホテルの宿泊代も高いから
ゲストルームを設けたんだ
ここがゲストルームだよ
いいね
この位置にある理由は
遠慮なく使える場所を
作りたかったから
夜遅くまで仕事したり
パソコンのスピーカーを使ったりして
家族を起こす心配を
させたくなかった
もう１つトイレがある
皆が泊まりに来るとき
いいね
夜にトイレを使っても
ここからの音が
聞こえるわけがない
２階だし
中庭をまたいでるからね
開けてもいい？
どうぞ
広い！
もう１人泊れそうだね
物が入るスペースが欲しくて
スーツケースとか？
そう　あと布団２組
そっか
同時に２人泊る時のためにね
上の段はスーツケースとかカメラの
機材が入るし コンセントもある
充電か
そう　バッテリーを充電したり
カメラを充電したり
配慮が行き届いてる
子供はこういうの好きだよね
ここから “ パパ！” ってね
この高所からナーフを
打つのも楽しそう
視聴者の関心を引こう
窓からあれが見えるなんて！
あれ皇居じゃない？
位置の説明として ここがシューズインクローゼットで
向こうがキッチン
これはまた別の収納
そこだけでも
いい感じ
ソワソワする
この時点でもう
いいオフィスじゃない？
建築家が言ってたのが
家で仕事することって
結構 大変で
生活したり寝たりする場所で
仕事をしてると
難しいのが
仕事モードと
オフモードの区別
この話は本当に大事だ
僕も寝室で動画を
撮ってるから大変なんだ
そう　難しいんだよ
いつ寝ようとか
いつ休むとか
そうそう
仕事は終わったけど
同じ姿勢でネットフリックスを見て
どっち？　みたいな
父親としては家族と過ごす時間も
しっかり取らないと
オフィスに入ろう
いいね
すごすぎる
防音対策もされてる
あれかっこいい！
言ってた何倍もいいじゃん
説明が下手すぎだよ
最高
最初の段階で聞かれたのが
“ リモートワークで
一番大変なことは？ ” っていう質問と
“ 何を変更したい？ ” っていう質問だった
分かると思うけど
部屋で撮影すると
部屋が三脚の森になる
それ
自在に変えることができて
十分明るくなるように
どうにか照明器具を
設置できないか聞いたんだ
今 使ってる照明の三脚を
ここに置かなくて済むように
いろいろと考えてくれた
それで
こんな感じで
天井にライティングレールを取り付けたんだ
普段はこれらを使わないで
代わりに
間接照明
これだけでもきれい
天井がカーブしてる理由として
本当に効果があるのか
分からないけど
箱みたいな部屋では
音が響くらしいんだ
確かに響きが少ないね
失礼
いえいえ
この方向と
こっち方向に声を出す
違うよね
確かに
こうすると
うん
そして
この後ろには…
すごい
ここに机を置くんだ
それがあの机？
そう　昇降デスク
このままだと窓の縁にぶつかっちゃうから
もう少し手前にずらそうと思う
“ 窓がある所には緑もないと ” って
建築家が言ってたから
開けるとあれが見える
向こう側にパントリーがある
なるほど
うん
これさ——
パントリーとキッチンが
指令本部みたいだね
分かる？
向こうにいれば皆に指示を出せる
“ 皆 行くよ ” ってね
そうだね
これが自分の部屋って
言えるなんて
僕たちのリアクションはあるけど
道元自身はどう思ってるの？
言葉にならないくらい
うれしいよ
君たちのような人にとって
いい環境にしたいんだ
他にもクリスとかジョーイ
ガーントやコナーなどの友達にもね
その人たちが歓迎されていると
感じられるような場所で
一緒に話したり
動画を作ったりしたい
ただの道元の家じゃないんだ
この建築家と
関われたのは光栄で
せっかくの機会だから
自分の限界を超えて
自分だけでは到底あり得ないものを
つくりたかった
クリエイターとしては
ここにいるだけで何かを作りたくなる
そうなんだよ！
ツアーをしながらも
“ ここであれを撮れるな ” って思ってた
日本の家はすごく好きで
前にも話したけど
伝統的な日本の家は——
デメリットも多い
でも この家みたいに
近代的な要素を加えると
うん
いいとこ取りな感じ
そう
日本建築２.０みたいな感じ
そうだね
カメラ越しでは
伝わらないけど
匂いと
触った感触がすごくいい
僕はいろいろ触りすぎて
道元に怒られてるよ
中庭に進もうか
そこでゆっくりしよう
ぜひとも
これのおかげで
頑張ろうって思えるよ
以上 僕の家でした
本当にうれしいです
とても感動しました
家関連の動画を
数本 上げる予定ですが
工事の流れとか材料の
家に関する質問もあると思います
費用の内訳とかね
コメント欄に質問していただき
別の動画で答えたいと思います
ノームとマヌの動画もぜひチェックしてください
この家についてコメントしています
僕よりも彼らのほうが
こういったコンテンツ作りが得意です
すばらしいクリエイターたちなので
概要欄から彼らのチャンネルをチェックしてみてください
いつもサポートしてくれてありがとうございます
次回の動画でまたお会いしましょう